твої друзі ми всі матчі маслом та ще
плани
кремлівського маразматика путіна ще до
виставкові провини бліцкригу в Україні
повністю право тут
третій день континентальні провини показав
все одним з головних завдань кремля та
настання і закопування наші ставити нашого
видного києву і сама тому за раз вся
україни при que todo боїв за наші місця
на піцу пах до києва оборону відкривають
pedrotti вас бро індекси україни а
саме місце за раз захищають битві
територіальної оборони
наверші ядро ​​зробити територіальною
оборони києва сторони нашою командою у c
206 падинський батальйон у числі всякого вже
отже, більше не було заплановано
батальйон прямо навчаючись у боях і над і
ступах до Києва за крима на сто миль
ваших місцях домагався прорватися з
ворог бійці батальйону
за рахунок нічного вести диверсійні
групи
росіян та
дізнаються і нас три ви можете піддаватися
на в кого ми не на наших воїнів на си
геть і шалено prophecy на пі готова не
алла їхній дух
вода їх до бою
на прольоті шкода ми відкинув етики
стрілочку збрую я не говорю за
харчування ти сьогодні три нових 1 літра
павла тип це не мій дістати не жарт ви
вирішили масами а ви одна з головних
проблем
на 8 ерік when i як і дві тисячі
п'ятнадцятому уроці ми не трюма ви для
наших бід сил жадібно ваші ломи
жадібного бронежилетом
і проблема тому, що все харчування нам
дістати нескладно ви лише тому що
маса випуск броні жувати вашу волю губ
і написано 19 уроків а
ви знаєте я до чотирнадцятого роль люди
готові на і без союзів і стіл і ти
проти гарної армії за хрести ти свій
україни своєї батьківщини щоб за христа це
фактично 8 цивілізований вигляд
ми готові
значило ти русню до тільки може avaya
перекований щоб їх заснуть риба не
текке в Україні а за іміджем і на
території Росії та акція бокові
обстріляли ракетами
Міллер та інша проблема що фактично
два роки була заморожена ракетно
програма і сьогодні армія німа neptune
німа верхи для того, щоб можна було за
300 kion цих завдає удару російською
території та
сама тому я хочу згорну тобто до наших
партнерів то наших стратегічних
партнерів доз отримані штаті док
crying нато цінуйте ки наша вина
цілі на святого діла з вина я каста
suite подальше розвитку цивілізації c
винаяк ви означає що повернеться
фашистка сталінської чума знову на території
на європи і тому нам потрібне не текке
морально допоміг нам потрібно реально
тугіше налаштований на вимагатиме
оперативно-тактичних ракет і щоб за
рахунок та російські за гірники ви будете
точок нам потрібні з учасник системи по
щоб ісламу ти іменування росіян в
українському небі
давайте 15 ви
і разом прям ага ти
псих ризикових звучати цих пакетів як
розв'язала провину
всім залишити
які знову поставлю світло на чоловікові
катастроф розум випий може